Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Lucas from Massachusetts. Lucas,
welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hey, David,
I hope you're feeling better.
Speaker 1: I'm feeling a lot better. Yeah.
Speaker 2: Glad to hear it. Okay, so
here's what I'm going to talk about,
please. The treadmill yesterday had a treadmill
thought. I know that this information is a lot
like the COVID virus and that we'll never
eradicate it. We can take measures to bring
it under control, and we should by doing zero
in feeling zero, COVID isn't sustainable,
if that makes any sense that I hear you think.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, nobody's doing
zero COVID anymore. I don't know.
I mean, like, sure, I'm friends.
Speaker 2: With it for a while.
Speaker 1: Yes. Right. But when I look on
Facebook, I still see a few people I'm friends
with who seem to be saying we should be doing
something close to zero COVID and everybody
wear masks forever, everywhere and all this
different stuff. It's just not going to happen,
you know? And I try to focus my conversations on
harm reduction, minimize issues, etc.. And I do
think that we just have to be sort of realistic.
But yeah, you can only do I mean, listen, way more
Republicans died. We now know because way fewer
Republicans got the vaccine. What were we going
to force them to get vaccinated? No, but it's like
you provide the information, you do what you can.
Speaker 2: Yeah. But like with disinformation,
I know you support media literacy courses
and I agree. Yeah. I just think is very
important because you're not suppressing
all the possible. The central mission like
that kind shock. The Internet would not
be worth it. Media literacy would really
work. Almost like a vaccine, you know? Yeah.
Speaker 1: No, you're hopefully inoculating
people from falling for fake news.
Speaker 2: Yeah. And, like, never got a
media literacy course at school because I'm out
of high school now and college. But, um, yeah,
that's just what I wanted to say. And like I said,
glad you're feeling better. And I enjoy the show.
Speaker 1: Lucas powerfully
said, I appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: All right.
Speaker 1: Take care. All right. You,
too. We're going to take a quick break, but we're
still taking calls. So if you're holding on to
talk to me, don't hang up. And then we'll
get right back to the phones in a moment.